high blood pressure or hypertension is a
common condition in which the force of
blood on the walls of your arteries is
often too high
arteries are the blood vessels that
carry blood away from your heart to
supply your tissues with oxygen and
nutrients in your heart two chambers
called ventricles contract with each
heartbeat to push blood to your lungs
and through your arteries to your body
as blood flows through them three main
factors affect the pressure on your
artery walls the first is cardiac output
or the amount of blood your ventricles
push out of your heart each minute your
blood pressure goes up as cardiac output
increases the second factor affecting
your blood pressure is blood volume or
the total amount of blood in your body
blood pressure also goes up as blood
volume increases
the third factor that affects your blood
pressure is resistance which is anything
working against the blood flow through
your arteries several factors contribute
to resistance one resistance factor is
the flexibility of your artery wall
healthy arteries expand with each
heartbeat to help reduce blood pressure
on the wall
another resistance factor is the
diameter of your arteries your body is
able to increase the diameter of your
arteries to lower your blood pressure
or reduce the diameter to raise your
blood pressure
a third resistance factor is blood
viscosity or thickness in your blood
more particles such as proteins and fat
increase viscosity if your blood is
thicker your blood pressure goes up as
your heart works harder to push it
through your arteries
your blood pressure can be measured with
a device called a sphygmomanometer or
blood pressure cuff
when your heart beats the pressure of
blood on the walls of your arteries is
called systolic pressure
when your heart relaxes between beats
pressure on the artery wall is called
diastolic pressure
while your blood pressure may change
throughout the day it should normally be
less than 120 millimeters of mercury for
systolic pressure and less than 80
millimeters of mercury for diastolic
pressure if your systolic pressure
frequently stays above 140 or your
diastolic pressure frequently stays
above 90 you have high blood pressure
over time high blood pressure will
damage the walls of your arteries
your artery wall may become weak
and form an enlargement called an
aneurysm or the wall may burst
and bleed into the surrounding tissue
small tears in your artery wall may
attract certain substances in your blood
such as cholesterol fat and calcium to
form a buildup called
a plaque
blood flow through your artery decreases
as the plaque enlarges blood cells can
stick to the plaque and form solid
clumps called clots further reducing or
completely blocking your blood flow
damage to your arteries raises your
blood pressure even more by making your
heart beat more forcefully artery damage
and reduced blood flow lead to
conditions such as a stroke
heart attack
or kidney disease
in most cases the cause of high blood
pressure or hypertension is unknown this
type of high blood pressure is called
primary or essential hypertension
treatment for essential hypertension
includes lifestyle changes such as
eating a healthy diet
if you are sensitive to the sodium in
salt your doctor may recommend limiting
your intake of salt and highly processed
foods
sodium may cause your body to retain
water which increases both your blood
volume and your blood pressure
other lifestyle changes that can reduce
blood pressure include avoiding
excessive alcohol intake
getting regular exercise
losing weight if you are overweight
and quitting smoking
your doctor may also recommend
medications that act on your kidneys
blood vessels
or Hart to help reduce your blood
pressure
diuretics commonly called water pills
cause your kidneys to move more salt and
water from your blood into your urine
which reduces your blood volume and
pressure
beta-blockers reduce the workload on
your heart by decreasing both the rate
of your heartbeat and the strength of
your hearts contractions several types
of drugs act directly or indirectly to
reduce your blood pressure by relaxing
your blood vessels which increases their
diameter these drugs include ACE
inhibitors angiotensin ii receptor
blockers calcium channel blockers and
direct-acting vasodilators